Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, die Ausgabe Nummer 12. Immer noch und wieder vom Chaos Communication Congress, dem 22C3 aus Berlin. Auch heute wieder ein Live-Interview. Mit im Studio ist diesmal Eric Blossom, der auch ein Redner auf dem Chaos Communication Congress ist. Wir haben jetzt den dritten Tag durch. Morgen ist aber noch ein letzter Tag mit vollem Programm. Bis 20 Uhr gibt es wieder zahlreiche Vorträge in vier Sälen. Und wer von euch noch dazustoßen möchte, der sollte sich das wirklich überlegen, ob er das nicht vielleicht noch tut. Wir erwarten euch auf jeden Fall am Alexanderplatz in Berlin. Am Mikrofon, wie gewohnt. Okay, ich wechsel jetzt zur internationalen Sprache, die gut gehört ist im Chaos Communication Congress. Und mit mir jetzt ist Eric Blossom. Du lebst in der wundervollen Reno. Und es ist nahe dem Ort, wo das Burning Man Festival stattfindet. Also bedeutet das, dass du jedes Mal da bist?
Es ist ein riesiges, dünnes Leib. Das, was mich immer über das Thema beeindruckt, ist die Größe der Menschen. Es gibt verschiedene Gruppen, die zusammenkommen und sie haben ein Thema. Die Grundlage für Burning Man ist, dass man die Eierpläne bringt. Da geht Musik all die Zeit, in verschiedene Plätze. Ist jemand das organisieren?
Es gibt einen Grupp, der es organisiert.
In der Dase. In der Playa. Vergesst es nicht. Und in der Ende wird alles gebrannt. Der Mann. Er ist jedes Jahr anders. Er ist auf einem großen Pedestal. Ende August. Ja, es ist heiß.
Es wird nur heißer, wenn es fängt. Du arbeitest mit Technologie, ich denke, seit einem langen Zeitpunkt.
Als Kind war ich immer einer der Menschen, der Dinge von sich bewegen wollte. Wie macht man das? Du warst dann an Technologie? Das war in den 70er Jahren. Die Universität hatte gerade einen neuen Computer. Was cool war, dass du real-time Feedbacks hattest.
Du bist aktuell wahrscheinlich best known für deine Aktivitäten im Gnu Radio-Projekt.
So dass die Leute ihren Code und den Effort betreiben und es eine Gemeinschaftssource bietet. Das ist ein Kind von Signal-Prozesse, die man bieten kann.
Real-time Signal-Prozesse klingt sehr kompliziert, aber es könnte zum Beispiel ein Radio sein. Aber das Radio in deinem Projektname hat nichts mit Radio zu tun?
Du ein digitales Kommunikationssystem hast, das du bauen willst. Wenn wir Radio sprechen, dann auch Televisions-Technik.
Wenn ich alle Software auf dem Gnusradio-Bereich herunterlöse, habe ich alles, um meinen Computer zu beherrschen, wie eine Radio-Station.
Und du brauchst einiges Hardware. Wir haben noch nicht alles aus dem Software-Radio erledigt.
Das ist ein Web-Server oder das ist einfach ein Tool, das einfach nur eine Sache macht. Es ist einfach mehr ein System für das Unterfassen der äußeren Welt.
Ein Teil davon ist die Frage, was die Menschen bauen wollen. Wir können technisch viele FM-Stations gleichzeitig aufregen. Dann können wir sie jemandem ausfüllen, um sie in MP3s oder Augs zu kompressieren.
Ist das fast genug?
Ja, und die Grundlagen sind in der Codebase.
Wo ist der heutige Limit? Wer ist jetzt hinter dem Projekt?
Er war interessiert, wie ich meine Ideen für Software Radio machen konnte. Und dann, über die Jahre, hat er noch Geld verwendet. Einige von diesen Geld haben wir durch die National Science Foundation in den USA, die akademische Forschung finanziert. Es ist eine Art, wenn du denkst, dass du Dinge abnehmen willst und siehst, wie sie funktionieren. Es ist eine Frage, ob du die Samplen in den Disk schaust oder sie in den Luft schäfst.
Ja, ist die Antenne verbunden oder nicht? Der Titel war Ich kann Airplanes sehen und es ging um die Anwendung passiver Radarsysteme.
Die Idee mit passiver Radar ist, dass wir jemand anderes Transmitter von einem Existenz-FM-Broadcast-Transmitter oder einem Televisions-Transmitter anbieten.
Also der Transmitter, den wir hier reden, ist etwas wie ein normaler TV-Transmitter.
Es ist ein bisschen wichtig, auf welcher Frequenz sie arbeiten, welche Band sie arbeiten. Das ist etwa 1000 Dollar.
Es gibt viele Fliege, nicht nur auf dem Flugzeug, sondern auch andere Frequenzen, die sich einander bewegen und so weiter.
Wo es nicht so faszinierend war, wenn man auf einem Flugzeug fliegt, sieht man, dass die TV-Firma wickelt.
Es braucht auch ein Prozess, um zu kalibrieren, um zu schauen, wie die Signale kommen?
Dann können wir feststellen, wie weit sie von uns sind und was der Doppel-Schifte ist und die Frequenz ist. Du brauchst einen Ort, um es zu setzten.
Und du siehst den Flugzeug. Also heute hattest du deine Rede. Für mich war es ziemlich kompliziert.
Und es ist ein Mix von Leuten mit guten Ideen.
Aber auch Codern, Programmen, alles. Es ist ein gutes Mix, oder? Es ist nicht das erste Mal, dass du hier bist. Wie reflektierst du die Kongresse?
Auch wenn es viele verschiedene Meinungen gibt, gibt es einen unterliegenden Begriff an Technologie und den sozialen Impact.
Du warst noch nicht in unseren Camps. Wenn du die in den USA vergleichst, gibt es welche ähnlichen Unterschiede, die du beigest?
Ich habe noch nie die Haupt-US-Einheit, die DEFCON, gesucht. Wenn ich es denke, dann benutze ich es im Publikum. Aber wenn du jetzt mit Menschen sprichst, die es verstehen, dann ist es so, dass die europäische und die amerikanische Sicht sehr ähnlich sind. Hacking geht nicht nur um Computer, es geht um alles. Sein, es könnte Chemie sein, es könnte Botany sein. Ich denke, dass Hacker diese Widerstandswürde bringen. Es ist keine gewinnbare Situation für sie.
Ich hoffe, dass wir uns wieder an den nächsten Events der CCC sehen und wahrscheinlich auch an anderen europäischen Events. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die europäische Netzwerke.